Mario, how you doing? Mario, you're
you're not speaking. Going once. Hey,
can you Yeah, I hear you. Mario, Mario,
you're not a Muslim. But yeah, I um I
had my shahada recently. How recently?
Once. But last time we spoke, I I
thought you wasn't really a a Muslim.
No, I said I aligned with Islam when we
spoke last time. I didn't have a stance
on what we were talking about. I think
the question was, is Jesus better than
Muhammad? I didn't have a I didn't
really I don't really align with that.
kind of like what the guest a few a few
um guests said ago. I think that I'm not
going to call it disingenuous, but I'll
say that it's more difficult for someone
who still does believe Jesus is the
Messiah and has a high respect for Jesus
to kind of like attack that question in
the proper way cuz I don't want to
disrespect Paul or Jesus in any way. But
I do, but I said I don't believe that
Jesus is God. That makes me not
Christian. And I believe that way
before. So you're So you are a Muslim
cuz I'm I'm confused on where you're at,
brother. you last time when I asked you,
you wasn't a Muslim, but you like you I
I just want conversation. If you if
there's anything you want to ask, I I'll
have a genuine conversation, but I'm not
I didn't have any conversation with you
last week to trap myself or anything
like that. Last week, I told you that
I'm not a Christian because I don't
believe Jesus is God. If you're a
Muslim, this this stream is for the
Muslims to join. So, if you're a Muslim,
you can you can engage if you're a
Muslim. Are you a Muslim? Yes, I am.
Okay. All right. Cool. All right. So,
yeah. So that's that's what the the
topic is that Paul and and Jesus are
better than Muhammad. Okay? And I am
pushing back on that. And I'm not saying
that Muhammad is greater than either of
those. I'm saying they're not greater
than him. Well, Jesus is the Messiah. So
I do consider Jesus the greatest, but as
a prophet and if we're talking about
teachings or we talking about the life
they live. Yeah. So you think that
Muhammad is equal with Jesus the
Messiah? I'm I'm talking about his
teachings. You you believe that
Muhammad's teachings is on par is equal
with with Jesus's teachings. Yes, I do.
Okay. I believe I believe that um
Muhammad reaffirms what Moses taught to
me. Okay. All right. Let's let's put
that to the test here. All right. All
right. So, um you you follow you follow
hadith, right? No, I only read the
Quran. I've only been Muslim for a few
months, but you can enlighten me. Br
whatever you would like into the
conversation. Yeah. So, the hadith are
sayings and teachings of Muhammad that
he did. I'm I'm aware of them. Yes, I am
aware of them. All right. So, they also
tell you what the Quran is, too. So,
without the hadith, you don't know
anything about Islam. Pretty much
enlightenment. So, it tells you the
history of the Quran. It tells you
Muhammad about Muhammad and his history,
his wives, what he did in his life, um
how he got the revelation. Yes. But I
ask teachings or lifestyle. I would
compare Muhammad to me personally a
prophet like David or Solomon. Oh man,
he's even worse than them. Yeah, I
respect your opinion, but I I I'll state
my case on those two. Yeah. All right.
So, this is what this is what Jesus
teaches. Yes. And uh in the gospel,
Jesus teaches turn the other cheek,
right? Forgiveness. Jesus teaches
forgiveness. Jesus teaches to love your
enemies. Yes. I agree. Not just your not
just your neighbors, but your enemies,
too. Yes. Okay. Do you think do you
believe that align with what Moses
taught? Of course it does. And but it
doesn't line up with what Muhammad
taught is the point. What I said that I
think I think Jesus is not I said Jesus
and Paul are neither better teachers
than Muhammad because I think that his
teachings line up with Moses. Are they
both greater than Moses? I'm about to
show you. Yeah. Jesus Jesus is better
than Moses 100%. Moses doesn't come
close. Paul as well. Yeah. Everybody
that's in the kingdom is greater than
anyone that was before. So everybody
born like for example Jesus says that
John the Baptist was among all those
born of woman John the Baptist is
greater than all of them but the one
who's least in the kingdom is greater
than all those. So are we only going to
use the word are we only going to use
the bi the Bible for our ar ar ar ar ar
ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar
ar ar arg argument because if I'm making
a case from Islam and you're making a
case from the Bible or Christianity and
we base factuals the facts off the
Bible, isn't that like a slanted
conversation? I'm using both the Bible
and the Quran. In order for us to know
what Jesus taught or what Moses taught,
we need to go to the Bible. Would you
agree? Jesus or Moses or Jesus and
Muhammad? Jesus and Moses. Okay. Yes.
Right. And so to see what Muhammad
taught, we need the Quran and the
Hadith. Would you agree? Correct. Right.
So, we're going to be using both. We're
going to be using both sources. We're
going to be using Islamic sources and
we're going to be using biblical sources
to see what each party taught, what
Jesus taught, what Muhammad taught, and
see which one is better. Okay. So, are
are you speaking on teachings outside of
the five pillars of Islam? Cuz that's
what I that's what I follow, the five
pillars. You follow Muhammad. So, I'm
going to show you what Muhammad taught
and I'm going to show you put it side by
side by what Jesus taught. And so when
we put when we put two and two side by
side, what Jesus taught and what
Muhammad taught, we're going to see
which one is a is a better teaching.
Okay? And what is that verse? I'm going
to show you a verse that Jesus taught
that's going to be directly opposed to
what Muhammad taught. And I'm going to
ask you which teaching is better. I like
that. Let's do it. It's up to you. All
right. So over here we have what
Muhammad said Muslim 2167 Abu Herrera
reported Allah's messenger may peace be
upon him as saying do not greet the Jews
and the Christians before they greet you
and when you meet any of any one of them
on the roads force him to go to the
narrowest part of it and that's what
Muhammad taught you read that let me let
me um read that reread that Yep. Let me
uh let me zoom it in too so we can see.
Do not do not greet the Jews and the
Christians. Do not greet the Jews and
the Christians before they greet you.
And when you meet any one of them on the
roads, force him to go to the narrowest
part of the road. Okay. And this is a
hadith. Yep. Authentic. It's sahi
Muslim, so it's authentic. It's probably
This is what This is what Jesus teaches.
You have heard that it was said, "You
shall love your neighbor and hate your
enemy." But I say to you, love your
enemies and pray for those who persecute
you, so that you may be sons of your
father who is in heaven. For he makes
his son rise on the evil and on the
good, and sends rain on the just and the
unjust. For if you love those who love
you, what reward do you have? Do not
even the tax collectors do the same? And
if you greet only your brothers, what
more are you doing than others? Do not
even the Gentiles do the same? You
therefore must be perfect as your
heavenly father is imperfect that is is
perfect. So which teaching here is
better to answer to answer your question
comparing these two teachings? I would
say the teaching of Jesus is better in
these two. Okay. But um but while you
while you have these, can you search um
a a Quran verse for me? What do you
need? Could you um search a Quran verse
that I would like to share? Yeah. Yeah.
What's the verse? The verse is surah
albakar 262. What's the chapter number?
Um chapter 2 verse 62. Okay. So talking
about the Jews and the p and the
Christians and the sabians have nothing
to fear if they believe. Yes. So how do
we coincide these verses that you just
gave me with the the verse from the
Quran with the verse that I just gave
you? Yeah. The verse go to go ahead and
you you had it on your phone, right?
Yeah. I just pulled up to see what verse
it I can read it if you want me to read
the verse. No, no, you don't have to
read it. Okay. Um, if you're using your
phone, I just wanted to make sure you
you were using your phone. So, similarly
around here as well. Good. All right.
This is what I think about this is what
I think about that verse. Okay. By using
another verse to interpret that. Okay.
Indeed, this is 98:6 of the Quran. Yes.
It says indeed they who disbelieved
among the people of the scripture and
the polytheists will be in the fire of
hell abiding eternally therein. Those
are the worst of creatures. Yes.
Polytheists. Not just polytheist but
Jews and Christians too. People of the
scripture. Well well I would say that
there are people of the scripture many
of you many people of the scripture do
not agree with each other. Would you
agree to that? What does that have to do
with this verse? Because there are
people who are of the scripture that
Christians also believe are going to
hell. that who are who are polytheists
or not. That doesn't that doesn't
address what this is saying. This says
not just that we're going to hell, but
that we are the worst of creatures
because we disbelieve in Islam. That's
not what I see. But I'm not saying
that's not what it says. But I I see
polytheist. Let's do this very slowly.
Indeed, they who disbelieved among the
people of the scripture. Can we slow
down a little bit more? Disbelieved
what? In Islam. It's talking about
Islam. What? What? What is the belief of
Islam? One God, right? Muhammad,
Muhammad being the messenger and his
prophets being Abraham, Moses, Muhammad
being, but is that not a part? Because
they already the people of the scripture
already believe in these prophets. They
just reject Muhammad. Also, people of
the scripture Jesus, Avery, I'm sorry.
There are people of the scripture who
reject Jesus as well and reject the
Trinity as well. You're you're right.
And this this is why they're not this is
why they're not people of the scripture,
not in Christianity. This is so do you
so do you agree that these are Jews and
Christians? Do I believe that people of
the scripture are Jews and Christians?
Yes. According to the Quran, I will say
I'm not sure but I believe there are
people who use the Bible as their
scripture. So just just so just to make
it clearly so just to give you just a
little little nugget. Yes. In the Quran
the people of the book or the people of
the scripture are the Jews and
Christians. That's what they're referred
to. Okay. Is there is there somewhere
where it names them that people of the
book are Jews and Christians? All over
the place. That's where you get the
context of if you want like we can
that's a whole another lesson. I just
want to ask a question. Hold on. Hold
on. Cuz cuz right now I have to I have
to teach Islam right now before
debunking it. And that's what's killing
a lot of our time. So the people of the
scripture, the Jews and the Christians
and the polytheists.
Okay. So these are different groups
here. The people of the scripture and
the polytheist. You see and the
polytheist. I do. Okay. So two groups.
the people of the scripture and the
polytheists. So these are the Jews and
Christians and then there are the
polytheists.
Those among these people, these groups
who disbelieve will be in hellfire. They
are the worst of creatures according to
the Quran. You see how it says that they
that those are these groups who
disbelieve are the worst of creatures.
Yes, I do. Okay. So this would include
like for example Satan. Satan is a
creature. Would you agree? Yes. The
Quran says that Jews and Christians and
polytheists who disbelieve in Islam are
worsening Satan. Worse than any creature
ever. They're the worst. I understand.
Yes. Yes. Can Can I Can I respond to
that? Yeah. Go ahead. Okay. Um, now
we're not going to agree on everything
because we're going to have different
interpretations when we read the book.
There are people who read the same book,
which is the Bible and the Gospels, and
come to totally different conclusions.
So, we cannot always expect that we're
going to read the same thing and think
the same thing. Is that fair? I'm about
to respond to this. I just wanted to ask
a question. Is that fair that we can
read the same thing? I am. I just wanted
to make a statement. But, but to respond
to that, I will say that um and to my
understanding in the Bible, worshiping
many god and idolatry is a very severe
sin. Yes, it is. Right. Nowhere in the
trinity. I'm sorry. Yeah. Let me let me
let me just let me be clear so that you
know what we're dealing with, Mario.
Okay. Nowhere in the Bible does it say
that the disbelievers are the worst of
creatures. Nowhere in the Bible does it
say that. In fact, it says it says, let
me finish, please. Okay. In fact, it
says I only spoke for about 15 seconds,
Avery. And I know it's your show. I
respect that, but I would like to have a
dialogue if possible. If you if you want
to have a dialogue, bro, then let's not
do that. And when you say things and you
and then you're getting a response,
don't play a victim and act like you're
not allowed to speak here. Don't don't
do that because then that'll just get
you kicked. I just want to go ahead. I'm
I'm quiet. I appreciate it. I appreciate
it. So, this is what the Bible says
about those who disbelieve. It says this
Romans 5 specifically verse 8 here. It
says, "But God shows his love for us in
that while we were still sinners, Christ
died for us." So the Quran says that
those who disbelieve in Islam among the
Jews and Christians and the polytheists,
they're the worst of creatures. They're
worse than the devil. The Bible says
that those who are disbelievers, while
they're even still being disbelievers,
while they're still sinners, God loved
us and died for us. You see the
difference? I do. Okay. So, go ahead. If
you wanted to give a response or
comment, go ahead. A comment. Right. My
my response to that would be um I Jesus
has also told people among him that you
do the will of your father who was in
hell. So that would that not be Jesus
calling them children of Satan? Yes. He
called those those Jews the sons of the
devil. He sure did. So So is that there
are there a big difference between the
sons of the devil and the lowest among
you? Yes. I think that saying that
you're worse than the devil is is
different than saying you're the son of
the devil by your action of not
believing. Right. I would say I would
think I would say those things sound
similar because to be a son of the devil
sounds like the worst thing I could
possibly be as someone who's trying to
make it to heaven. If you're the son of
the devil, are you the are you worse
than the devil? I'm his spine. I'm If
Jesus is the son of God. So to become
equal to God. Are you worse than the
devil though? I'm equal. Like Jesus is
equal. You're equal. This says in the
Quran you're worse than the devil. So
what's better? Being equal to the devil
or being worse than the devil? That's
better. But I would say they're not far
off. I will give you that. They're
off. Okay. Um, are you able to pull
those back up or did you already take
them down? Yeah, I can pull them back
up. Okay. So, so far we're seeing that
Jesus has teachings that are better than
Muhammad so far, right? Yeah. I mean,
maybe we could get into Paul or someone
else, too. But I I'll take the tough
heel first. I'll take Jesus. Jesus is
the Messiah. I will say that Jesus is
did not have better teachings than
Muhammad. I am in no way calling
Muhammad better than Jesus. I want to be
clear on my stance. But yes, that's a
conversation we're having. So, could I
pull up a scripture now? How you I have
another one. Yes. Yes, sir. Okay. So,
you're still under the under the thought
that Jesus did not teach better than
Muhammad. Well, I still have a few
points to make, but um yes, I am. Okay.
So, we already saw that we're two for
two for Jesus. Right. Right. We're two
for two for Jesus. Well, I the the
scripture that I pulled up from the
Quran, I feel combed your scripture and
you gave another scripture from the
Quran to combat my scripture. So, I feel
like that wasn't a one for one. How did
how did how did how did 262 combat what
Jesus says about loving your enemies and
greeting even the your enemies? No, I
used that to combat what you said about
Christians and pushing them to the
narrow part of the road. How? Because in
that scripture that I gave in the Quran,
it said that Christians and Jews and
Savians who believe in the Lord in his
last day will not have anything to worry
about. And I also applied that Jesus
also let it be well the Bible also lets
it be known that idolatry is a very
serious sin. Yeah. But what does that
have to do with how how Muhammad teaches
you how to treat Jews and Christians?
Just because Allah are those all of his
teachings? Yeah. If if the Quran says
that believing Jews and Christians won't
have anything to worry about on the day
of judgment, but Muhammad is teaching
also to force them to the narrowest the
dirtiest side of the road and don't even
greet them. Those are two different
things. It's not that's not an answer to
how Muhammad taught to treat the the
Jews and Christians. You get what I'm
saying? I disagree. But yeah, I think I
think it's like if I take a Bible
scripture to try to contradict Jesus
being God or someone shows that Jesus is
God, those scriptures aren't necessarily
in tandem. And maybe there could be a
context added. So, as of right now, I do
not agree. But how does that Yes. So,
Mario, how does that relate to what
we're talking about then? How does I I
need you to relate that to what you did.
You brought up a verse in 262 that says
that the Jews and Christians who believe
will have nothing to fear, but you have
Muhammad teaching how to treat the Jew
and the Christian, not to greet them and
to force them to the narrower side of
the road. So, how does the the believing
Jew and Christian having nothing to fear
on judgment day change how Muhammad
taught to treat the Jew and Christian
here in this? I want I want you to
understand what I'm saying that the
second scripture that you gave from the
hadith. I do not know the context of
that. For all I know, Christians and um
Muslims may have been at war during that
time. There may not something going on.
I just said, "For all I know, you're
giving me new information. I'm only I'm
just trying to speak right now and let
my thoughts be made clear. That's all.
I'm not saying that I'm right. I'm not
trying to say that you're wrong. I'm
saying that what you said from what I
read is not in tandem. And I and if
someone showed me something in the Bible
that went against another part, I would
not immediately say, "Oh, this
contradicts the Bible." Do you get what
I'm saying? I give the Quran the same
grace. That's So then do you agree then
that the Quran verse that you gave does
not even touch the hadith I showed you?
Well, I feel the as far as the worst
creatures and me saying that um No, no,
no. I'm not talking about that verse.
I'm talking about Muhammad how Muhammad
taught to treat the Jew and the
Christian. Are are you able to leave
them up on the screen? Sure. Thank you.
I appreciate that. So you you think that
this answers the hadith? The um
scripture that I gave 2 262. Yeah. You
think that answers the hadith? No, I
think that that was the belief that I
have discovered and lined up with. So I
showed that. I didn't know about the
hadith you showed me until just now.
It's like that was the first thing I
showed. I showed the hadith first and
then in response to the hadith, you
brought the ver the 262. You thought
that that was like a a answer to to the
hadith somehow. No, I'm just showing
another teaching of Muhammad. That's
all. And I know the context of that
teaching. I I understand that he's
saying that if you are a Christian and
you believe in one God or a Jew or a
Sabian that you can you will still have
a good outcome in the I got you. So
reading both of these, do you agree that
262 does not touch the content of this
hadith? Do you agree with that? When you
when you say doesn't touch it, you mean
they're not connected or they don't
they're not connected. It doesn't answer
this. It's not related. Yeah. I wasn't I
wasn't promoting promoting it as an
answer or to relate them. I was
promoting it as you put two, you think
about this, Avery, you put two teachings
up. So, should I not be allowed to
present scriptures that I align with?
You gave two examples. Am I only
supposed to go with the examples that
you put up or do I get to go to other
parts of the book myself and display and
highlight those? I don't think that
you're realizing what what is going on
in this conversation. Break it down. I
I'll be quiet. Okay, Mario, I need you
to pay attention. Okay. Pay attention,
please. I'm showing you the teachings of
Jesus in comparison to the teachings of
Muhammad. What I did was is I gave you a
hadith that shows what Muhammad teaches.
And then I gave you a Bible verse on the
along the same lines on the subject of
what Jesus taught. Muhammad is telling
you how to treat those you disagree
with, your enemies. And then Jesus is
teaching you how to treat your enemies.
I lined them up side by side and asked
you which one is better. You said the
teaching of Jesus is better. I did. And
then but you said in response to this,
you wanted to give a verse 262. So with
the flow of how that was going, it seems
like you were giving 262
in response to this hadith. But maybe
that's not what you were doing. You were
like, "Okay, you know what? I see those
two teachings. Okay, boom. Let me show
you something. Here's 262." So, you're
showing me something completely
different. Is that what you were doing?
I I appreciate you seeking to understand
what I was saying. I was I didn't
understand that you were displaying how
to treat your enemy. I thought you were
only displaying m um Muhammad's opinion
on Christians. So, I offered another
perspective that he also wrote about.
But if that was about enemy for enemy,
now I understand and I have a new
perspective. Okay, fair enough. So we
see how Jesus what Jesus teaches how to
treat your enemy and how Muhammad
teaches how to treat your enemy are two
different two opposing things and we see
that Jesus's teaching was better than
Muhammad's in this category. Would you
agree? Um I said to the original one yes
but I said earlier that I felt that
Muhammad's teaching aligned with Moses.
You said you feel that that Jesus was a
greater teacher than Moses. Okay. All
right. So with that being said, let's
show some more. But but but can I be
honest? Um, I want to just say that I
don't I don't believe that it's always
better to um just allow your enemy to
treat you any type of way and to forgive
them. That's not what Jesus says. He
doesn't say allow your enemy to treat
you any type of way. He just says to
love them in spite of Does he not say
turn the other cheek when they slap you?
That's still not saying to treat them in
any type of way, but he's saying to
choose forgiveness and to choose justice
rather than your own vengeance. Well, I
understand that to be allowed to be
treated any type of way. If someone
slaps me in my face, I think they're
extremely disrespecting me. And for me
to turn the other side of my face, I
don't think that's always the right
thing to do. Yeah. I think that that is
uh I think sometimes I will follow
Exodus. Well, that's fine. Sometimes I
will follow the teachings of Moses.
You'll follow Exodus. Well, I won't just
say Exodus. I'll just You know what? Cuz
you you want to you want to leave the
teachings of Jesus. So, let's go to
Moses because we're going to see that
it's not fair to compare the Messiah's
teachings with Muhammad's teachings cuz
he's just going to fail every time. I'm
I'm only I'm only just having the
conversation with you for fun. Let's go
to Let's go to Moses. Yes. Let's go to
Moses. I know that this is the topic,
but I'm just want to ask by the end of
this, would you be willing to have the
Islamic dilemma or the Aisha
conversation with me? Depends on where
this goes. Wait, you're okay with Aisha?
I just said, would you have the
conversation with me? I would like to
propose my point. Maybe. Maybe one day.
If uh are you okay with it? Are you okay
with him sleeping with Aisha at night? I
I think I think it's sin. You think it's
sin? Yes. Okay. Well, good. There's
nothing to talk about. I think the
prophets have sent and they're not
they're no longer not prophets. Okay, no
worries. If you're willing to follow
Muhammad who says that God is the one
who told him, we're just having a
conversation. We don't have to make it
personal, brother. We're just having a
conversation. Well, I never said
anything personal. It's You said if
you're willing to follow, who is you? Is
that is am I not talking to a human
being in front of me? I said we're
speaking on teachings. You're saying if
you're willing like mean if you're okay
with doing whatever you want to do. It's
simple, Mario. If you, Mario, are
willing to follow a prophet who sleeps
with a kid and says that God told him to
do it, that's on you. Are there are
there not prophets who have worshiped
idols or who have killed people over
their wives who they were lusting over
and things of that nature? You follow
those prophets? Did did God tell them to
do that? No. God did not tell Bash Bash.
Exactly. God punished David for that.
Right. But is he no long you still do we
still
God punished David for that? I question.
Yes. But we So very So very good. So
follow the line. Follow the line of
thinking. Mario, God punished David. God
disapproved of Solomon. Did God punish
or disapprove of Muhammad sleeping with
with Aisha? I I don't know. Muhammad
said God showed him Aisha in the dream
as a confirmation for him to marry and
sleep with her. Okay. Did Did God tell
Abraham to kill his son? We can go from
extreme to extreme, brother. But if if I
had a dream about killing my son. Are
you good? I do. Are you good? Yeah. You
good? My bad, bro. You good? What did I
say? That was That was bad. No, what
you're saying is getting It's getting to
like the level of stupidity like right
now. It's is getting But you're smarter
than this, Mario.
I'm giving you the benefit of the doubt.
You're smarter than this. I'm I'm allow
I'm here for you to be allowed. So, if a
prophet said if some if a prophet said
that God told me to sleep with this
little girl, is that a true prophet? Can
I answer the question with a question?
If God told me to kill my son, is that a
true prophet? Yeah, go ahead. Answer the
question with a question.